your there's something about you this
year that just blew me away that's come
out of you and the strength that's come
out of you yeah using your voice for so
much positivity yeah how is this your
been for you you know I I mean I've said
it before but I feel like when you make
room in your life for happiness and and
just really loving every minute of it I
think that it happens and I've done that
I mean we have a lot we have four kids
and I'm happily married and and I love
my friends and like everything I was not
fine wood to knock on cuz I feel like
the rugs gonna get like it was ripped
out from underneath me but no
everything's just so great I love who I
work with I love my I love my album so
much like all of it so yeah have you had
the chance to reflect on how people are
reacting to the yeah I mean we've been
doing shows and everybody even the songs
like we've actually put like four new
songs and this set like usually you only
put one or two yeah but we don't care
and some foreign and literally they're
singing all the words like so it's it's
it feels good because you know when you
love something so much you're like watch
this not hit cuz I love it so much but
ya know it's working still love so soft
yes the brominated for a granny how did
you find the cuts my husband woke me up
and he said you're not in for agreement
I was like you liar I was like cuz I'm
not even I thought I was eligible the
2019 right so um cuz my record but my
records not eligible but my song was so
I'm excited I'm excited not just for me
but for the writers Priscilla mo Jessie
like they did such a great job and
really nailed what I wanted to
accomplish with this album and the sound
and everything so I'm really stoked the
holidays are coming up
yes holiday tradition appeared you're
prepared all our we're gonna be here to
wrap underneath the tree did you do all
choppy yes you did yep and I wrapped
them all - except for wine my husband
did that yeah that's me yeah did your
kids have a center or what my year old
wrote a letter to Santa with her cousin
Izzy they're writing letters to Santa
and she asked him for boobies mermaid
boobies and tail and I was like all
boobies until you're like your daddy
awesome but yeah she she's obsessed with
Ariel and her little shells she wears
the tail okay she asks for a mermaid
boobies she asks Dana that's her first
letter to Santa I love ask for boobies
and she'll I don't know maybe she'll be
into women was there a memory for you
and for the holidays this is always
about family it's all about celebrating
each other because their memory from
your childhood that you keep with you
forever um you know what I actually I
didn't really realize it was a bummer at
the time in them and I did it was a
bummer like we didn't have a lot of
money but I didn't really know the other
families had tons of gifts or did all
that you know anyway so we didn't really
have a lot but I actually really
appreciate that that I grew up without a
lot because I I think I really get with
the actual meaning of Christmas is more
because I it wasn't ever about presents
for me because I knew I wouldn't get
much so but it wasn't I think I think
it's the best way I'm my husband I
always have this talked about our four
children we want to we both grew up
without a lot of money so you know it's
hard to like navigate that when you're
trying to raise kids and make sure
they're appreciative and grateful and
know the difference but it's kind of our
constant challenge yeah with our kids
but and I'm sure you have that with your
kids so but it's yeah I love that I grew
up though like always having to work for
everything and I think I appreciate
things and I I see things you know my
vantage point is a little different than
most so and you know what hard work is
right yeah you know how hard work is and
you know what it means to like you know
my mom put a keyboard like a that I
wrote my first songs on on a credit card
and I knew she shouldn't have done it
she went into debt for it and other
things like paying bills but but it was
it was one of those things that really
meant a lot to me cuz I knew she didn't
have the money so it wasn't like some
kind of flippant present you know so
yeah I know I think I appreciate them
the family part of it the playing games
the watching movies the hot cocoa that's
tough yeah he went on a date on James
Corden with her husband I I know people
think I had an idea I had no idea like
first of all for a million dollars I
would've lost a million dollars if dota
said oh we got your husband to be on the
show no sir he does not get on TV he's
standing back there he would never be in
front of a camera and as you can tell he
was sweating and it started talking
about it's cold if you wanna watch it
but
I don't we don't but like I was like it
but it is you don't know because you
don't see the cameras but there are
literally like 30 cameras and like a
little bitty tiny cameras everywhere but
nobody but and then he gave us a farm
report it was awesome I think he should
be on camera more people every time
people say I loved your James Corden
carpool karaoke they're always talking
about Brandon not meaning they're
referring to him but it's awesome you
could play the next day did you see
mother he's waving
[Laughter]